we are in for a very warm easter weekend
and your plans might include hitting the
pool
and if you have young kids public safety
crews are reminding you to be extra
careful around water bianca holman is
live here at noon
to show us what to remember hi bianca
well with kids on spring break and temps
in the 90s many of you are probably
cleaning out your backyard pool
but before the first splash here are
some things you want to keep in mind to
keep everyone safe
now drowning is a leading cause of death
in small children
fire officials tell us drowning
accidents are preventable
with the three p's so here they are the
first is patrol an adult should be
watching children at all times in any
type of body of water not just the pool
that includes bathtubs also protect the
pool area
with a barrier or a gate and then
prepare put your child in swimming
lessons
or as an adult take a cpr class
it takes just a few seconds all too
often we hear
i had to go and answer the doorbell i
had to answer a phone call i looked away
for just a few moments
these little ones are adventurous and if
those uh in the movies you see the
splashing and the screaming
the reality is is these are silent
terrifying
terrifyingly silent events where a child
in just a matter of seconds can slip
below the water
we're told parents should even be more
alert around pools without lifeguards
such as apartment complex or backyard
pools
and unfortunately we have learned that
just this year there have been two
reported drownings bianca holman 8 news
now
yeah it is so important to remember it
happened so quickly bianca thank you for
that